in kemberg in sachsen-anhalt bringt ihr
wird thorsten kattner seine pferde jeden
tag von seinem grundstück über die
straße auf die koppel direkt gegenüber
eigentlich denn vor drei wochen hat ihm
die stadt diesen bauzaun forst
vorgestellt der grund auf ihrem weg zur
wiese sollen die pferde die straße
beschädigt haben
thorsten kattner ist stinksauer für mich
war es totalen schock ich will die
förderung aus bringen und ich komme
nicht kommen nicht aus männer aus meinem
tor vor jahren wird der weg zwischen dem
grundstück und der koppel aufgeschüttet
und das feld irrt die folge es fahren
mehr autos und bei starkem regen gibt es
fortan immer wieder probleme mit der
entwässerung der straße nachdem thorsten
kastner 2011 den bauernhof übernimmt
macht er die stadt auf die zustände
aufmerksam
er bittet darum dass die schäden
repariert werden die reaktion der stadt
die pferde hätten dem wasserablauf
kaputt getrampelt deshalb müsse er alles
auf eigene kosten reparieren der streit
geht jahrelang hin und her vor drei
wochen dann schafft die stadt tatsachen
und macht den weg zur koppel mit einem
bauzaun dicht um jetzt von hier nach da
zu kommen müsste er mit den pferden über
viel befahrene straßen laufen ein umweg
von knapp 500 metern bekloppt
unverständlicher behörden sprechen wir
doch mal wie das so typisch ist ein
unterschied den eigentümer irgendwas was
überhaupt nicht mit dort sachen
entspricht das hier mit dieser
wasserrinne das problem besteht ja schon
seit jahren nicht erst seitdem er ist
das finde ich unverschämt
das müsste eigentlich der stadt machen
und ja so wie jetzt dafür aufkommen was
falsch gemacht wurde spricht beim
straßenbau im kemberger rathaus will
sich zu dem fall niemand vor der kamera
äußern
es handele sich um ein laufendes
verfahren schriftlich heißt es da es
wohl auf einen rechtsstreit hinaus
laufen wird kann ich ihre
interviewanfrage leider nicht zu sagen
die pferde müssen im stall bleiben
thorsten kattner und viele kemberger
können die sturheit der stadt nicht
nachvollziehen
mich nimmt das unheimlich mit dass die
voerder tagtäglich 24 stunden im stall
sein müssen ich finde es unmöglich die
tiere geht machen nichts kaputt gehen
über die straße auf die koppel auf
allgemeinen trend so dass die meisten
öffentlichen immer mehr abwälzen auf der
anwohner am ende wird wohl ein gericht
entscheiden müssen wann der bauzaun
wieder wegkommt und thorsten kappen dass
pferde endlich wieder auf ihre koppel
dürfen